okay so this is how you should be
warping to the round table hold
done
it's literally that easy now be honest
how many of you are still dragging your
cursor there manually instead you just
have to press triangle or y to open the
list of grace checkpoints and then you
press square or x to confirm a warp
straight there it took me way too long
to discover that this was a thing but
elton ring is full of little quality of
life things like this that are never
explained so i'm going to quickfire for
moritu for example if you walk through a
beacon of light that you've placed the
beacon will disappear so this is an
excellent way to mark that you've
actually reached your destination
without having to pull up your map
next if an enemy explodes in a burst of
blue light that means they're going to
drop an item don't miss it and when you
do pick up an item take note of this
icon this tells you which category of
your inventory that item just went into
this will make it way easier to figure
out what you just picked up
another great way to go over your recent
loot is to press l3 on the inventory
menu this will let you sort in order of
acquisition and look over all of the
items that you recently looted at the
bottom by default though your inventory
is sorted into vertical categories that
are demarcated by these horizontal lines
for example the bolstering materials tab
organizes your flask materials your
smithing stones and your sombra smithing
stones into their own sections every tab
is like this now with those quality of
life tips out of the way let's get into
the big stuff
first off how would you like to have a
buff that gives you five percent extra
runes to get this all you have to do is
type in seven letters so in the last
secrets video i announced secret seekers
which is our community group to join
enter the password seekers in all caps
as your first group password in your
multiplayer tab and you'll be able to
identify phantoms blood stains messages
and summon signs from other people in
the group our goal is to find secrets in
the game and to share them with others
and since then you know i can't go five
minutes without finding evidence of you
guys hurling yourselves off cliffs in
search of secrets i look at scenes like
this covered in blood and you make me so
proud but since then we've also
discovered that every time someone in
the group defeats a shard bearer or
becomes elden lord everyone else in the
group receives a five percent buff to
their rune acquisition and you know
considering there are thousands of you
in this group this buff activates like
constantly so join us and enjoy your
free runes also i put the secret seekers
logo onto a shirt so if you want to rep
our unofficial covenant check it out in
the link below another way to get free
runes is by duplicating your
remembrances godrics for example gives
20 000 runes and subsequent bosses give
even more than that every major boss
drops a remembrance though the proper
way to use them is to trade them in for
boss items at enya the finger reader at
round table hold and here you'll realize
that every remembrance can be traded in
for multiple items so it's possible to
duplicate them at the walking mausoleums
that are found throughout the game
here's what some of our testing revealed
first there are seven walking mausoleums
in total one in limgrave
three in leonia
one in the mountaintops of the giants
one in the consecrated snow field and
the last in the deep root depths the
method of bringing down a mausoleum
differs in most cases i'll let you
figure it out but it's generally related
to removing the white curse marks from
their body and it's worth finding your
way up to each of these because you can
only duplicate one remembrance per
mausoleum after duplicating that
mausoleum becomes pretty obsolete
interestingly you don't actually need
the remembrance in your inventory to
duplicate it you just have to have
defeated the boss you got it from also
note that you cannot duplicate
remembrances that you have already
claimed all of the items from
and finally make sure to use your
duplications before heading into new
game plus because your remaining
duplications won't carry over
in addition to receiving a remembrance
defeating a shard bearer will also grant
you a great rune once acquired you have
to go to its corresponding divine tower
and activate that great rune after doing
this you can equip a great rune at a
site of lost grace with your equipped
rune appearing in the top left of your
screen these great runes bestow powerful
effects upon your character though
equipping the rune doesn't apply its
effects instead to do that you'll have
to consume a runark these powerful
consumables are a reward for invading
doing co-op exploring the world they're
basically like embers or humanity from
previous games in the sense that it's a
powerful buff that doesn't disappear
until you die
you also get them from killing rats just
like humanities and embers from previous
games the law here is that you know even
the most valuable items in the world
make their way down to the bottom of the
food chain to the rats that consume the
bodies of all every great rune does
something different godric's for example
increases every one of your attributes
by five which sounds low but then you
have to remember that's essentially
granting you 40 extra levels for a
limited time
characters that use a wide variety of
spells and scalings will benefit most
from this of course
but some of the later great runes are
even more powerful
but if you don't have a great rune
equipped then a roonarc will just
increase your max hp by about 10
so run arcs aren't really worth using
unless you have a great rune equipped
but remember make use of runarchs don't
just let them sit wasted in your
inventory you know next to all the other
consumables that you're afraid to use
equip them to your pouch and pop one
whenever you're on a really difficult
boss because it might be this item that
pushes you over the edge to victory
ranala's great rune is a bit of an
outlier from the others unlike the
others it can't be equipped and it
doesn't need to be activated by a runark
rather it can be used to respect your
character talk to ranala at reya lukaria
and you'll be able to bring your
character back to their starting stats
with all of your previous levels ready
for reinvestment this process requires
that you defeat ranala of course but it
also requires that you have a larval
tear these are very rare but to tell you
about the location of at least one
there's a royal soldier located here in
limgrave that drops one
be careful though kill him and he might
just be reborn and new but elton ring is
a long game so as you pick up your 50th
meteorite sorcery you might start to
think
yeah maybe i want to play a sorcerer so
respect try something new switch it up
it's easy to do you just have to kill
this guy for a larval tear it's so easy
right another way to fix your character
might be via pardoning which let's be
honest is a mechanic that exists for
when you put down your controller and
you accidentally press the r2 button in
front of an npc alternatively it is also
useful when giant dogs attack npcs
through walls and they get upset at you
instead
so to get npcs to forgive you you just
need to find celestial dew one of them
is located here for example and then
take it to this pool at the church of
val's in researching this i started to
wonder what this mechanic is really for
and i think i figured out it must be for
the merchants
because logically you should be killing
every merchant you see because once you
kill them you can just buy all of their
items in one place at the twin maiden
husks at round table hold
that said it's very traumatizing to kill
a merchant just listen
[Music]
it's all my fault please don't hurt me
i said don't hurt me
so if you regret this decision ask for
forgiveness and the merchant will become
friendly again if you really do have
some angst to let out you know don't
take it out on npcs that don't really
exist
take it out on other human beings like a
normal person
your item for infinite invasions is the
bloody finger which can be acquired by
progressing vary's quest line to the
rose church speak to him before
defeating godric at the start of the
game and then again at the rose church
in leonier located here here he'll give
you five festering bloody fingers for
invading other players use three of them
to progress his questline where he will
next require you to soak the lord of
blood's favor in the blood of a maiden
one maiden exists here in the church of
inhibition in leonia interact with the
maiden and return to vary to receive the
bloody finger alternatively you can pick
up the recusant's finger at the volcano
manor you get this later in the game and
this one has a different story
affiliation to the invaders of the
bloody finger that you got from vary but
if you'd rather just engage in jewels
with other players then you'll need the
duelist's full finger which can be found
on a corpse at the doors of stormhill
coliseum the small red effigy can also
be found here and it serves the same
purpose except it sends a competitive
summon sign to the summoning pool
instead summoning pools are accessible
at these effigies found throughout the
world and if pvp is something you'd like
to avoid entirely well pick up the white
cipher ring from the twin maiden husks
of the round table hold with this buff
active you'll automatically request help
from another player when your world is
invaded and if you want to be the player
that helps invaded players then you can
just use the blue cipher ring instead
also in the round table hold is fear the
deathbed companion embrace her and
you'll receive a boulderkin's blessing
now and it's kind of funny that not many
people realize this but did you know
that your maximum health is reduced
while you have this blessing in your
inventory
yeah so this debuff icon means that
you're losing about five percent of your
health and it's a debuff that remains
until you fully use herbaldicon's
blessing and i don't blame people for
not realizing this the buff and debuff
icons get pretty intense in elden ring
and as a side note icons with a square
around them are permanent effects from
rings and ones with diamonds around them
are temporary but the biggest question
here is is the baldicon's blessing worth
it and the answer is
kind of sometimes the baltic ins
blessing essentially gives you a type of
poise for about 15 seconds once it's
consumed this is extremely useful when
you're facing a lot of minor enemies as
you'll completely ignore their small
attacks and only get staggered by their
strong attacks however the blessing
seems pretty pointless when you're
facing a single enemy or any large enemy
so i'd honestly only recommend bothering
with this mechanic if you know that
extra poise will serve you well in an
encounter to come like in a cave with
lots of rats or demi humans or flying
projectiles but the main reason to go
back to fear every now and then is
because you'll eventually get a dialogue
option for progressing her quest line
for me this always appears once i've
moved into the altus plateau
also enjoy the cuddles you know or don't
you can also just warp out of there if
you think the animation is too long
though things like this are why you're
maidenless you know
for number 14 have you ever found
yourself disappointed with the amount of
armours that you can alter well you can
actually expand your options by
acquiring the gold sewing needle in
leonia in a chest to the right when you
enter the church of vows located here
this lets you modify godly attire so
stuff like rinala's set for example
furthermore if you've progressed box
quest line in limb grave after talking
to him here
and here then you'll eventually find him
again in leonia at the east raya lucaria
gate here buck will perform your armor
alterations for free even taking the
gold sewing needle from you if you
should so desire and if you can't find
him here that means he's moved on to
lane dell
finally everyone knows about the
whetstone knife at the gateside ruins
that lets you apply ashes of war but did
you know that there are also additional
wet blades in the game finding these wet
blades will unlock additional scaling
options the most accessible early game
wet blades seem to be the iron wet blade
which adds keen heavy or quality scaling
and is located in stormvale castle or
the glintstone wet blade which adds
magic scaling located in raya lucaria
and that's it thank you for watching
special thanks to absa who helped me
with a bunch of the research for this
video and again check out our secret
seekers covenant and merch if you're
interested subscribe for more elden ring
content and i'll see you next time